rachel is a baker who runs her own
bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a blog she began
posting on her blog regularly
however even after regularly posting on
the blog there were barely any visitors
showing up
deciding not to give up rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across seo or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before
so let's take a journey together and
help her learn about seo search engine
optimization is a method that could
improve the quality and quantity of the
audience coming to rachel's website from
search engines
it could increase brand awareness
attract local customers and build
credibility and trust
and all of this is possible without
having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of seo on-page and off-page seo
rachel first decides to tackle on-page
seo and get that sorted
on-page seo involved rachel optimizing
her website both in terms of content and
the technical aspects including the html
source code schema meta tags and more
she started off by using tools like
google adwords allref and semrush to
identify popular search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics
once she found these search terms she
began to incorporate them into her
recipes
she started off by providing an
introduction to the recipe with this she
could provide an engaging beginning to
her story like how the dish reminded her
of her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people
after this she moved to the website meta
content that search engines display when
her blog appears in search results she
optimized the meta tags alt tags header
tags and more this completed the on-page
aspect of seo
thanks to this she saw a significant
increase in the number of visitors
coming to her page having done all she
could on her web page she now decides to
explore what could be done off page to
improve her page's visibility on search
engines
off-page seo involved rachel doing
things outside her site page to help
increase its search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked unlinked
brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like facebook twitter and instagram as
well as niche platforms like horror
reddit and medium
these could help her achieve greater
reach for her website by sending
stronger social signals to search
engines
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences
and even after understanding and
implementing all of this rachel had just
scratched the surface of what was
possible with seo
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz
which of the following is the most
effective way to improve off-page seo
one creating plenty of web pages of a
content
two
getting backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites
three acquiring backlinks through link
buying
four
none of the above
let us know your answer in the comments
section below
do you know that 75 percent of searchers
never click past the first page of the
search results
moreover as per the research carried out
by backlinko only 0.78 of searchers
click results from the second page of
the search results
if you notice this is a negligible
number showing minimum or no possibility
that the user will click on your website
that appears on the second page that is
why you need to appear on the first page
of the search result and rank high
and this makes search engine
optimization
also known as seo one of the most
crucial aspects of digital marketing
a very warm welcome to this new video by
simply learn in which you will get a
brief overview of search engine
optimization
by the end of this video you will have a
better understanding of digital
marketing and its components
we will have a brief look into what is
seo and its importance
next we will understand how search
engines work
and what are different types of seo
moving forward we will discuss essential
tools required for best search engine
optimization practices
and finally we will end the session by
understanding case study job scenarios
and what the future holds for seo
before we begin consider subscribing to
our channel and hit the bell icon if you
love our videos
so without any further ado let's first
briefly understand what digital
marketing is
traditional marketing strategies like
newspaper advertisements pamphlet
promotion billboard advertisements are
slowly overtaken by digital marketing
promoting products and services on the
online platform using digital technology
is called digital marketing
now you must be thinking for sure that
what are digital marketing methods
through which one can promote their
products and services on the internet
let me tell you there are several
components of digital marketing let us
have a quick look at each one of them
first we have search engine optimization
also known as seo
with search engine optimization one can
get relevant traffic through search
results with the help of search engines
we will understand this more clearly as
we move ahead with this video
next we have social media marketing also
known as smm the promotion of products
and services using social media platform
is called social media marketing some
social media platforms include youtube
twitter
facebook instagram etc
moving towards email marketing it is one
of the important components of digital
marketing
promoting products and services through
emails is called email marketing
now let's know what affiliate marketing
is
when one business pays to another
business or influencer to promote its
products and services it is known as
affiliate marketing
getting to know about mobile marketing
mobile marketing promotes products and
services using devices like phones
tablets or mobile devices
some mobile marketing strategies include
sms marketing in-app advertisements
location-based advertisements etc
content marketing
content marketing is creating and
distributing high quality content to
attract relevant traffic content can be
of any form like a blog article video or
podcast
and the last one
search engine marketing also known as
sem
search engine marketing is a practice of
advertising the content such that it
appears at the top of the search results
page
it is also known as pay per click
we will discuss all the components in
detail in the upcoming videos in this
video let's focus on search engine
optimization
mid 1990 was the initial phase when
content providers started optimizing
their websites for search engines
by 1997
content providers started manipulating
search engines to get higher rankings so
algorithm for search engines were
regularly updated to lower the risk of
manipulation
in 2001 there were rumors that seo would
no longer be in action and would be
replaced by search engine marketing well
this never happened in these 20 years
various growing seo techniques have
improved the web presence of websites
and will continue for many more years
so let's understand what is search
engine optimization
the practice of getting traffic
organically through the search results
with the help of search engine is called
search engine
optimization although being one of the
most important components of digital
marketing
seo has had some myths floating around
it
let's have a look at them
only famous brands can rank high in
search results
yes it is a myth
with good seo techniques anyone can rank
high in search results
competitors are way too strong so it
isn't easy to rank high in this case
this can be a bit difficult but it can
be easily overcome with good competitor
analysis skills and one can attain high
ranks and search results
a website with more pages can rank high
well it depends on the quality of
content page has
if the content is high quality even the
website with fewer pages can rank high
to rank there is a need to spend a lot
of money one can rank high with some
strategies and techniques without
spending a penny
now that we have debunked the myths
around seo let's understand why seo is
important
seo increases the popularity of your
brand product or services among the
audience thereby increasing the chances
of conversion of lead to customer
traffic obtained organically is more
consistent
once you are aware of seo strategies and
start gaining visibility in search
results
your site will gain constant traffic
that will keep increasing with time
with seo one can reach a large audience
to promote products and services
businesses can acquire audiences from
both the national and international
levels
seo builds trust among the audience for
instance if your web page is available
on google search results the audience
finds it worthy of trust because of its
online presence
your competitors are doing it then you
should also do it this could be a
serious note
if your competitors are doing this to
rank high and gain visibility you must
also do it or remain back in the race
there are three types of seo that you
can implement for the growth of your
business
before moving towards it it is necessary
to understand how search engines work
let's understand it with the help of an
analogy susan started a business of
handmade toys
she failed to gain enough customers
using traditional marketing methods like
newspaper advertisements and banners
so she thought of putting the business
online thereby creating a website
the website was completely optimized for
search engines and was soon visible on
the search result pages
the website started acquiring the
traffic which ultimately became her
customers
the sales were boosted to an unexpected
level and the revenue has increased
exponentially
a good decision brought huge success to
susan's business
susan was thrilled with joy when a
thought struck across her mind
how are search engines able to find her
website
so
search engines can be google bing yandex
dub dub go etc which work on three basic
steps
that are
crawling
indexing
and
ranking first we will understand
crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send the web spiders also
known as crawlers or robots or search
engine bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image web page video
or anything else present on the web
this process is known as
crawling soon after the discovery of
content
web spiders start storing the url of the
content into the search index and this
process is known as indexing
once the content is indexed it appears
in the search results for the relevant
searches
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant search results are taken
from the index and displayed from most
relevant
to least relevant on the search result
pages this process is known as ranking
now as you're familiar with the working
of search engines let's dive deep into
types of seo
that is
on-page seo
off-page seo
and technical seo
we will start with on-page seo
optimizing a web page to gain visibility
and rank high in search results
and get relevant traffic is known as
on-page seo
some on-page seo techniques include
optimizing content
adding attractive titles and meta
descriptions
adding internal and external links on
the web page
adding ssl certifications for the
website
optimizing images for search results etc
next is off page seo
actions taken outside the web page or a
website to rank high in search results
is known as off-page seo
some off-page seo techniques include
building backlinks
blogging and submitting articles on
other websites
promoting content on social media etc
and the last one is technical seo
optimizing technical elements of a
website such that search engines can
easily crawl and index the web pages is
known as technical seo
some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a minimum
submitting site maps to search engines
have organized website structure as it
informs search engines about the
essential pages of the website
adding redirections for the deleted urls
or temporarily moving urls
identify duplicate content and replace
it with unique content
don't worry too much about it we will
cover these in detail in the upcoming
videos
now to optimize the website there are
lot of tools available
few from google and few third party
tools as well
let's have a look at these tools
keyword research tools includes google
keyword planner
keyword tool dot io rfs mos etc
on page of page and technical seo tools
rfs helps to estimate search traffic
know ranking history monitor outbound
links generate backlink reports etc
sem rush is helpful for competitor
analysis
generating new ideas for content
analyzing website traffic
website analytics
and more
google analytics helps generate website
traffic reports track activities like
bounce rate pages per session
track online campaigns when integrated
with adwords
it also has features to know a user's
location
how long the user stays on the website
tracking sales report etc
google search console helps to
understand
how the search engine sees the website
generates reports for clicks and
impressions of your page in search
results
carries out url inspection
submits a site map
finds error pages like 404 and more for
the website
here are some other tools that may be
helpful while working with seo
google tag manager helps add and update
google ads without changing site code
google trends helps get trend
predictions seasonal trends find
relevant trending topics etc
grammarly helps check readability that
is how easily your content is readable
for the user
checking pulsarism to maintain unique
content etc
page speed insights help analyze page
performance and suggest improvements for
a web page
now you must be thinking
can seo actually bring success to your
business well we have a small case study
for you to let you know how to go from
zero to hero
let's assume there is a company named
express bakers that has started a cakes
business
that focused on instant cake baking and
delivery
rather than choosing the traditional
methods of advertisements they decided
to put their business online
express bakers created a website for
their business and completed all the
technicalities like submitting site maps
ensuring easy crawlable site structure
and optimizing paid speed
soon their business started gaining
visibility in search results but still
the sales were low than expected
after hiring an expert they understood
that traffic on the website is very low
so they made up their mind to follow the
seo strategies thereby optimizing the
website
relevant keywords like instant cakes
cake delivery instant cake mix
instant cake delivery instant cake
delivery near me
instant flavored cakes etc were added to
the website pages
express bakers added cake images with
description time of delivery choice of
flavor and gate base and cost
all images were optimized with alter tag
so that search engines should understood
the image
relevant internal and external links
were added so that search engines can
discover other pages of the website
and users can find other products like
cookies and pastries by express bakers
express makers became smart during the
website
optimization they knew that to gain
massive traffic they needed to promote
their products on the website and other
public platforms as well
thus they added articles on instant cake
baking recipes
how to make flavored cake base instantly
how to make instant whipped cream and
many others on the blogging platforms
like reddit hub pages blogs by google
and also added the website's relevant
urls in the article
expressbakers were now unstoppable
they kept on posting on social media
platforms about their instant cakes and
delivery facilities which helped in the
brand building
efforts by express bakers increased
their brand awareness and attracted
customers to their product soon there
was an exponential growth in website
traffic and sales were at their peak
express bakers generated high revenue
through the increase in sales in just
few simple steps they got success in
hand
this is the story of success by express
bakers
all businesses dream of such success
so they try to get their online presence
thus there is a vast requirement for seo
executives in the market
in the upcoming part of the video let's
discuss various job roles under seo
with tough competition to rank on the
search engines and app stores there is a
huge demand in industry for seo experts
there are various types of roles in seo
some popular ones are
seo associate seo analyst seo executive
seo manager and seo expert
let's first talk about
seo associates
seo associate is responsible for
performing keyword research and
implementing seo strategies to improve
organic ranking
the average base pay of an seo associate
in u.s is between dollar fifty nine
thousand to dollar eighty thousand per
annum and in india is two lakh twenty
eight thousand rupees per annum
next is seo analyst
seo analyst is responsible for keyword
research competitor analysis tracking
organic traffic and conversion rate
the average base pay of an seo analyst
in the us is between dollar forty eight
thousand to dollar seventy eight
thousand per annum and in india
is two lakh twenty eight thousand rupees
per annum
understanding the responsibilities of
seo executives
an seo executive is responsible
for gathering analytics reports
creating seo friendly content and
implementing on-page and off-page
techniques
the average base pay of an seo executive
in u.s
is dollar 39382
per annum and in india is in between 1
lakh 92 000 to 3 lakhs 62 000 rupees per
annum
an seo manager is responsible for
analyzing reports of the campaigns
developing content marketing strategies
managing a team of seo experts
fixing technical seo issues
and more
the average base pay of seo manager in
us is dollar seventy two thousand six
hundred fifty two per annum
and in india
is eight lakh seventy nine thousand
rupees
moving towards the job responsibilities
of seo expert seo expert is responsible
for creating keywords and content
strategy link building strategies
competitor analysis and reports and
campaigning the average base pay of an
seo expert in u.s
is in between dollar fifty three
thousand two dollars seventy eight
thousand per annum
and in india
is two lakh seventy six 000 rupees per
annum
some companies hiring for significant
roles under seo are microsoft
disney
siemens
udemy and deloitte
before ending the session
let's know what is future of seo
as every online business wants high
ranking and visibility in search engines
seo plays a crucial role in the journey
of any business
thereby creating enormous job
opportunities and with companies
shifting to digital space
now more than ever after the pandemic
the importance of seo in the future
cannot be overstated
so let's try to understand what the
future holds for seo
let's first discuss urls
urls are the standard way of
representing the website's address thus
urls will remain an essential factor in
the coming future
next is auto generated content
machine generated content will be
accepted by search engines if and only
if humans have reviewed the content
before uploading
coming to page speed
as per the data provided by google
as page load time increases from 1 to 3
seconds
bounce rate increases to 32 percent
therefore by improving paid speed a user
gets easy access to required information
and so
paid speed will continue to remain a
significant ranking factor for future
seo
moving towards content creation
create content that focuses on user
search intent
add content that user needs as this will
be an essential ranking factor in the
coming future
keep the old content of your website
updated
if you are not doing so my friend you
lose valuable traffic
when you update the pages content
search engines are notified of the
update and updated content is again
indexed
adding more value to your page
if the page is not updated frequently
you may lose the search ranking within a
time span thereby losing traffic
backlinks will remain an important
ranking factor
as it shows other people's trust in your
content thereby adding a plus to your
rankings
is your website not ranking as you
thought it would
are there too many competitions out
there
is it getting difficult to capture
relevant audiences
are the solutions suggested too
expensive
do not worry in this video you will get
easy solutions to all your questions as
we have come up with the list of top 10
seo tools that anyone can use
and the best part is you need not to
spend a single penny on these tools
yes you heard it right they are free of
cost and are very useful for anyone who
wants to start an online business or
struggling to improve reach
so let's jump right into the list
but before we do
kindly subscribe to our channel simply
learn and hit the bell icon to never
miss on such interesting and useful
videos
to carry out best seo practices the
first free tool on our list is the
keyword planner
keyword planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by google
proper keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result pages
the keyword planner will help to
discover new keywords
estimate monthly searches a keyword has
get the cost of ads for the keyword
you're looking for
and help to organize keywords
let's understand how to use google
keyword planner
open your adwords account
now
go to the tools section and select
keyword planner
now you can either add a keyword to get
new insights or upload a csv file to get
search volumes of already known keywords
let's see how it works
click on discover new keywords
from here you can change the location
enter the key phrase for which you need
keyword insights
click on get results
here you can see all the keyword ideas
related to your keyword phrase
now to get the search volumes of already
known keywords go to the keyword planner
and click on get search volume and
forecast
now upload your csv file from here
here you will get search volumes for all
the keywords
other similar tools with free trials
include
keyword tool dot io
and keyword generator by rfs
to know trending ideas you can use
google trends
whereas to get title ideas you can use
the answer the public tool which is free
now let's see the next tool in the
bucket
google search console
google search console is a free
webmaster tool provided by google
it is important to timely monitor your
website and make it error free
this is where google search console
comes into the picture
it helps businesses to monitor and
maintain their website's presence in
google search results
some features of google search console
includes
getting confirmation that google search
engine can crawl your website
fix the problems in page indexing
sends pages for re-indexing
can view google search traffic data
records the number of times your website
appears in the search results
records the search queries for which
website appears in the search result
shows the list of sites linking to you
and many
more let's now understand how to use
google search console
here the total impressions suggest that
number of times your website appears in
the google search results
whereas the total clicks suggest that
number of times your website is clicked
from the google search result page
from the coverage section
you will get to know all the errors
occurred during the crawling
we recommend you to try your hands on
tools like bing webmaster tool
and rfs which is free for website owners
next up we have the used seo plugin
yoast seo plugin helps in improving your
search results ranking
it also free as well as a paid version
as a beginner you can quickly check the
free version
it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out seo analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at seo plugin
from here you can add seo title
from here you can edit the slug slug is
the part of url you can add the
necessary keyword here
in the meta description section you can
add the meta description
which all together looks like this
well
this part
is your slug the keyword you want to add
in your page should be added in the
focus key phrase section
the seo analysis section
shows the seo improvements in your
content
now moving towards the readability
analysis
readability analysis shows improvement
in the textual content of the page
if both the indicators are green
then your seo and readability both are
good to go
for yoast seo we have covered the
significant features and now we will
understand one of the essential seo
tools
google analytics
website tracking plays an important role
in seo it helps in understanding the
user behavior on your website
google analytics is an analytics tool
used for tracking a
website the standard version of google
analytics is free
we can integrate google analytics with
google ads
the main features of google analytics
include tracking session duration of
users
pages per session
and tracking website traffic and bounce
rate of users
let's take a quick tour of google
analytics
here you can see reports of users for
last 7 days
now go to the reports section in the
dashboard
you can reset the time span to get the
desired data from here
go to retention
where you can see the number of new
users and the number of returning users
to your website
to know the data on monetization
go to the monetization section
here you can see the monetization data
for the selected time span
we will understand google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail
moving ahead with the next tune which is
small seo tools pageranism checker
duplicate content is hated by search
engines
if not taken seriously this could hurt
your search rankings
the plagiarism checker detects duplicate
data in your content and shows its
source
you need to open this plagiarism checker
here you can add your content manually
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a verification
and click on check plagiarism
and here we get the results the content
is hundred percent unique
in case if we get any duplicate content
we can check the sources from here
as our content is unique we are not
getting any results here
in case if you don't want to enter your
content manually you can upload document
file from here
note that this checker checks for the
top thousand words of your content so in
case of lengthy content you can break
the content and then check for its
uniqueness
in case you don't want to purchase the
pro version
moreover you can also add a page url to
check the uniqueness of the content the
page has over here
and follow the same process by clicking
on the check plagiarism button
the plagiarism checker by grammarly is
also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content
the next tool that we have in our bucket
is the paid speed insights
as per the data provided by google the
bounce rate increases to 32 percent as
the page load speed increases from 1 to
3 seconds
page speed insights is the page speed
check tool
page speed insights is used to test the
speed of a web page and it is a free
service offered by google developers
results of paid speed insights show what
real users are experiencing about your
page on mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to
pagespeed insights and select the url of
the website for which you want to
undergo the check
enter the url and click on analyze
button
now choose whether you wish to undergo a
check for mobile or desktop device here
i'll select a desktop device
in few seconds you will get the required
results
another tool that we can use is
tools.pingdom.com
which has free as well as paid versions
moving forward to the next magic tool
which is
sem rush
to grow your business it is essential to
keep an eye on what your competitors are
doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and implement similar
strategies for your business as well
for this you need to carry out
competitor analysis
sem rush is the competitor analysis tool
that gives a complete walkthrough to
competitors data like keywords
backlinks
top performing content
campaigns
etc
it has free as well as paid versions you
can access free trials by simply signing
up on
semrush.com
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
log in to your sem rush account
here enter the url of your competitor
here you can choose a geographical
location
for which the analysis is to be
performed
by adding url you get all the competitor
data
here i have added sem rush as a
competitor so we are getting so many
details of sem rush
the organic keywords the organic traffic
paid keywords paid traffic
referral domains and authority score
we can add a competitor as well from
here
now here you can see the data of both
sem rush and refs
other than sem rush
you can use spyfu
which has some free daily trials
now let me tell you about an excellent
auditing tool
which is screaming frog
dear learners it is essential to know
how your website is performing
and for this you need to carry out
frequent website audits
streaming frog is a website auditing
tool that works similar to web crawlers
it has free as well as paid versions
some features of free version include
finding broken links errors and
redirects
analyzing page title and metadata
href lang attributes auditing finding
duplicate content etc with a crawl limit
of 500 urls
let's know more about it go to screaming
from
now
from here download the tool on your
system
check various resources provided
on how to learn the tool from here
another alternative tool you can use for
auditing is
seo ability where you can enter the url
and get the audit reports
moving further with another free tool
which is
rf's backlink checker
gaining high quality backlinks is an
essential factor for seo ranking as it
shows the trust of other websites in
your content
moreover it helps in building the
authority of your website
with the help of backlink checker you
get the data of all the websites linking
to your website rf's backlink checker
shows the data of top 100 backlinks
top 5 anchors
and top 5 pages
including total number of backlinks and
referring domains in its free version
let's have a quick look at the tool
here let's take example of wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
wikipedia.com
now click on check backlink
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink checker
are semrush backlink analytics tool and
seo ability
by signing up with these tools you will
get some free trials for your site last
but not the least let's know about the
mobile seo tool which is mobile friendly
test studies show that in year 2020 60
percent of traffic was through mobile
devices
thus it is essential to keep your
website mobile friendly as well
here is when the mobile friendly test
comes into action
it helps to check if your website is
mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly test
and enter the url of your website
suppose i enter your www.wikipedia.com
now click on test url
here you get the results
we can see that the page is mobile
friendly
to check more details you can navigate
to your search console account
well if you think we are done for today
then then keep watching this video as we
have two bonus tools for you
so here comes the first one
the serperator
search results vary with mobile devices
also your brand ranking may differ from
country to country
to get reports on this
circulator will be your all-time
companion it shows how search results
may differ for mobile devices or
locations
let's see how it works
go to circulator
now
let's fill in the required fields
now
let's select the location
let's run the live test
and here we get the results
that's it
daily you can run three free live tests
isn't this amazing
without taking a minute let's know about
the second bonus tool
which is
the rich results test
you must have seen these kinds of search
results on search pages
let's dive deep into it
yes these type of results are known as
rich results
to check whether your site is optimized
for rich results
go to rich results test
and add the url of your website
let's add the url of simplylearn
now click on test url
complete the verification
and check the report
so here we can see that simply learns
website is eligible for google searches
rich results
to monitor rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console account
every online business is in the race to
grab the first position in the search
results and hold on to it as far as
possible
to rank higher there are several factors
that we need to consider like
having unique content for audiences
having seo optimized website
having large number of backlinks
and a good social media presence
in this video
we will focus on what backlinks are
what make backlinks an important ranking
factor
moving ahead we will understand do
follow and no follow backlinks
pay your keen attention when we start
with white hat and black hat links
moving forward we will understand how to
build backlinks for your website and
finally we will check backlinks building
tools and future of backlinks
before diving deep into the topic
consider subscribing to our channel and
press the bell icon to never miss any
updates from simply learn
so let me demonstrate you how this video
will prove a game changer for your
online business
let's go to google.com
how to make pizza
so here you can see there are number of
results
uh these type of results are called with
snippets and below you'll get the list
of
top 10 search results
on the first page of the
serps
so here we are going to find
the backlinks for the first and the last
result
so let's copy the link
open it in a new tab and
copy the link and now we will go to rf's
backlink checker
just to add to your information rf's
backlink checker is a free backing
checker tool
now here we will be adding the url
and check backlinks
so here you can see there are 288
backlinks with the 22 percent of do
follow links we are going to learn the
do follow and no followings in the
coming part of the video so stay tuned
now let's check the backlinks for the
last search result
which is
here
we'll open the link and
copy the link here
go to rf checker
and add the url and again the same
procedure
so okay so here we can find that number
of backlinks are more as compared to
previous one here there are 346
backlinks with six percent of do follow
links
so now there is a question that though
there are there is
uh more backlinks in the
last resort why it's not why it's
ranking to the last position so here is
the answer
that
having more number of backlink is
definitely a ranking factor
but the backlink should be do follow
links
if you have more number of do follow
links then it is more likely to result
high on the search results as compared
to
less number of do followings
that's why
the last
that's why here you can see that
this link is at the last of the search
result
whereas this one inside the first
okay so
now again
let's search for best
jogging
shoes
okay
we are not taking the ads we will check
for the organic results which are here
so let's click on the first result
copy the link and go to
rf's backlink checker
add your url
and check for backlinks
meanwhile we'll go and check for the
last result
okay this this one is the last
copy the link
go to
rf's battling checker
and enter the url
check back links
okay
so here you can see a huge difference
the first first result is having
3395 with 94 percent of do follow links
whereas the last result is having only
183 backlinks with only two percent of
do follow links definitely to rank
higher there are several factors and
backlinks are one of them let's
understand what backlinks are
when a web page receives a hyperlink
from another website
it is known as a backlink a backlink is
also known as inbound links
let's understand this more clearly
this is an article on best pizza company
it has a list of visas mentioned
here you can see a link attached to each
company
when you click on the link it opens the
website or the company's home page
here the company's home page gets one
backlink from the website on which
article is present
now as we are familiar with what
backlinks are let's understand what make
backlinks an important ranking factor
when a web page receives more and more
backlinks
this helps search engine understand that
your web pages content is valuable
which makes other websites
to link to you
thereby gaining their trust
as search engines
loves the unique and valuable content
they consider it to rank high in the
search results
this makes backlinks an important factor
and a symbol of trust as well
however it is not necessary that if you
get lots of backlinks that means you
will rank high for sure
you will rank high only when you get
high quality backlinks
backlinks are said to be high quality
when linked juice or authority from one
website is passed to another
and to understand this
there is a need for proper understanding
of nofollow and do follow links
a website can link to your page either
by do follow
or by no follow links
do follow links are beneficial in terms
of seo when a website links back to your
site by do follow link it passes the
authority or the link juice
of their website to yours
this helps to improve the authority of
your website thereby positively
affecting the ranking
coming to nofollow links
these links do not pass authority or
link juice to your website therefore
these are not beneficial in terms of seo
however even though it directly does not
affect the ranking of your website still
no follow links are good for driving
user traffic
from one website to another
now that we have gained knowledge about
do follow and nofollow links i would
like to bring your attention to some of
the practices followed by optimizers to
get the backlinks
white hat and blackhead techniques to
get backlinks optimizers mostly follow
white hat or black hat techniques
the white hat technique helps to gain
backlinks under search engine guidelines
talking about blackhead techniques
these involves spammy methods of gaining
backlinks
and one can get penalized by search
engines
if search engines detect the black hat
methods so on a serious note we
recommend you to follow white hat
techniques strictly
so without taking a minute let's start
understanding the methods of how to
build backlinks
here we go with our first technique
which is skyscraper technique
this technique is originally said to be
found by brian dean the founder of
backlinko
publishing a skyscraper content can help
you to bring backlink from high
authority sites for this you need to do
the basic research and find the content
that is doing well in your industry
once you find the content create a
better version of this content with
additional unique information
now
all you need is to promote your content
then you can reach out to experts with
similar interest and ask them to add the
url of your content
which will be an add-on to their
existing content
and that's it
another method of building backlinks is
publishing detailed guides
detailed guides are the form of longer
content studies say that longer contents
tends to gain more backlinks
however
remember that publishing longer content
will work only if the content is unique
and informative
getting to know about broken link
building
all you need to do is
find the informative pages which are
relevant to your industry on the web
that have dead links or 4.4 pages
4.4 pages have a negative impact on
search engines
if you have relevant content that could
replace this 4.4 page
do reach out to the owner of the content
and have a humble ask
to replace the dead link with your
content definitely it's difficult but
yes this technique really works
next we can get backlinks by finding
listicles
to add plus to your knowledge
listicles are a piece of writings that
has list included in them
all you need to do is find the content
which has list of relevant topics now
check if it includes your site also
if not you can ask the owner of the
content to include your site with a
brief description of how it is helpful
and relevant to the existing content
now let's talk about another technique
helpful in gaining backlinks which is
guest blogging
guest blogging is a simple and easy way
to earn backlinks
first you need to identify blogging site
with high domain authority
create a blog post relevant to your
industry
with the links of your site and add this
post to the blogging sites
do not add too many links as they will
appear spammy in the eyes of search
engines which may prove harmful to your
site
next we move towards another technique
which is
link gap building
link gap analysis is the quickest way
from which one can easily discover the
link building opportunities
by carrying out link gap analysis you
can find the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
so suppose if you find a website that
links to more than one of your
competitors their chances of linking to
you increases
as we have seen some of the effective
backlink building methods now let's see
some tools you will need for building
backlinks using the above methods here
we go with our first tool helpful in
backlink building which is sem rush
it is helpful in competitor analysis and
finding link gaps
it has free as well as paid version
next we have rfs
link intersect feature helps to get the
reports on the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
this feature comes under the paid
version
upcoming tool is another interesting
tool which is helpful in building
backlinks which is group high
it helps you to get bloggers reach
this tool is a paid tool
next we have hunter dot io
it is an email address finder that helps
you to get email addresses of people
from a particular domain or even their
personal ids
it has free as well as paid versions
we have learned almost all the aspects
of backlink building
now let's have a quick look
at what is in the future of backlinks
backlinks are one of the most important
factors in search engine ranking as it
shows the trust of one site into another
gaining high quality backlink makes the
search engines understand that the
content on your website is valuable
thereby making it eligible for higher
rankings however due to spammy methods
backlinks are the factor that can be
easily manipulated
as we know that search engine algorithms
are continuously updated backlinks will
continue to be an important ranking
factor but the unique content and
user-centric content will be more valued
search engine optimization or seo has
proven to be one of the most important
factors in getting higher rankings in
the search results
seo strategies like image optimization
page optimization
backlink building
keyword research
etc are responsible for getting higher
rankings in search results however
keyword research has its own importance
in both the ways that is for organic
search as well as for the paid search
thereby
becoming an important part of search
engine optimization
in this video we are going to put a
light
and learn in depth about keyword
research for search engine optimization
but before we begin
please consider subscribing to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss any updates from simply learn
now let's have an overview of what we
are going to learn in this video
first let's understand what do we mean
by keyword research
next we will know about the importance
of keyword research
before going in depth about the topic it
is necessary to know what is long tail
keywords and short tail keywords
moving ahead we will check the list of
keyword research tools
further we will understand how to
perform keyword research
next we will understand how to do
keyword research with the help of
various tools
next we will see how keyword research is
important in grabbing the job
opportunities
where we are going to cover all the
roles and responsibilities
and finally we will end this discussion
by knowing the scope of keyword research
in the coming years
dear learners if you want to get
certified as a skill seo professional
that too for free
do have a look at the advanced search
engine optimization skill up course by
simplylearn check the link in the
description box below
so let's begin this interesting session
by knowing what keyword research is
yes we are definitely going to know what
is keyword research but before this it
is important to understand
what is a keyword
keywords are the ideas or topics that
clearly describe what your content is
about
say for example here the title of the
slide is what is keyword research
so this is the keyword which suggests
that
this slide contains the content about
keyword research
so basically
keyword research
is a process of identifying keywords or
popular search terms that people tends
to search for
when you identify relevant keywords
all you need to do is
include these keywords smartly into your
content and this will help your content
to get higher rankings and search
results now the question arises
why does keyword research has so much of
importance and search engine
optimization
let's understand this
keyword research plays a major role in
driving traffic organically to your
website or your content
but how does this exactly happens
when you select the most appropriate
keyword for your content
there is an opportunity
where you can rank high in search
results
by ranking higher there are more chances
that audience can discover your content
and reach to your website
thus you get more and more consistent
traffic growth for your website
thereby indirectly promoting your
products and services
now that you are aware of how keyword
research holds importance
let's now see some essential types of
keywords
that is long tail keywords and short
tail keywords so first we will start
with long tail keywords
long tail keywords are the keywords that
are mostly used to get more specific
results long tail keywords include
keywords with three or more words
for example
shoes for a black dress
now coming to short tail keywords
short tail keywords are the general
keywords or more specifically general
search terms short tail keywords include
one or two words in the keyword
for example shows
now let's see the difference between
both the long tail and short tail
keywords by demonstrating let's go to
google.com
so now we are here
to check the difference between long
tail keywords and short tail keywords so
first we will check for the short tail
keyword
now suppose i am looking for the shoes
that should go perfectly with my
beautiful black dress
so here i add shoes
and see how the results are appearing
okay if you see the recommendations here
we get shoes for men shoes for women
shoes images
shoe size chart shoes for rainy season
etc etc
and if i enter here
on the shoes what are the results here i
get number of results from the shopping
websites
with the very number of shoes
with number of brands and somewhere
locations of the shops
but none of the result is relevant
to
what i am expecting that is the shoes
for my black dress
okay so now
i'll just change
my search query
i'll add a long tail keyword here
and i will search here more specifically
for what i wanted
so here i'll add shoes for
black
dress
okay
so here i am getting number of ideas the
image ideas in the search result that
what kind of shoes are going to go best
with my black dress
and
here i'm getting several combinations
which i can wear with my black dress so
12 best color shoes
here again i'm getting
if you observe clearly then all these
results are completely aligned to what
exactly i am looking for
okay
and if i again change this query
more specific like shoes for black dress
for
woman
let's see what i get
so here i am getting more specific
results
in terms of women's
we will definitely understand how to use
long tail keywords or short tail
keywords during our research in the
upcoming part of this video let's now
have a look on tools required for
carrying out keyword research
here i have got a small list of tools
that you will need to perform effective
keyword research so first we will begin
with keyword planner
keyword planner
is a free keyword research tool provided
by google some of the important features
of keyword planner includes discovery of
new keywords
estimate monthly searches for a keyword
get the average cost of ads for the
keyword you are looking for
and help to organize keywords the next
tool that we have in our bucket is sem
rush
some important features of sem rush
includes
helps to get competitor keywords data
it helps to get competitor backlinks
data
finds competitors top performing content
helps in getting competitors campaign
data etc
let me bring it to your notice that sem
rush is one of the best platforms that
fulfill all your seo needs
so do visit to semrush semrush.com you
can find the link in the description box
below
next tool that we have in our bucket is
rfs the free keyword generator tool by
rfs helps to discovered keyword ideas
helps in identifying the search volume
estimations
identify easy keywords for which you can
possibly rank for
helps you to get a list of long tail
keywords
and however it is not limited to google
searches only yes you heard it right
you can get keyword ideas for google
bing
youtube
yahoo etc now let's check another tool
which is google trends
google trend will come into action
during your keyword research when you're
looking for the top search queries by
users
that is the most trending queries
moreover you can check these details of
search queries
for your country for any other country
or even worldwide
not only this but you can also choose a
type of search for this query like web
search email search youtube search etc
the next tool that we have is answer the
public tool
answer the public tool has free as well
as paid versions
this tool can prove a magic wand for
your business as it suggests the
questions that are asked by people in
your industry this can help you to
understand and create strategies for the
content that the users are searching
across the internet
and the last tool
in our today's list is
keyword tool dot io keyword two dot io
has free as well as paid versions
keyword to load io helps to get keyword
ideas from various sources like google
youtube bing
amazon
ebay
instagram twitter
pinterest etc
we will definitely understand how to use
these tools in the upcoming part of the
video
to make use of these tools it is
necessary to understand
how to perform a keyword research
as we have already seen
why keyword research is important
let's now see how to perform keyword
research
here are the top 5 ways to perform
keyword research to perform keyword
research it is important to understand
the domain and who the audience is
understanding the correct audience will
help you to get more correct keyword
during the research
for example if you are performing
keyword research for healthcare website
the audience would be a patient
or anyone who wants to know about health
center or a disease so with this tip
let's try our hands on the first keyword
research technique
which is keyword discovery
to get a list of keywords
use keyword research tools like google
keyword planner
rfs etc
now all you need to do is go to the
keyword research tool and search for the
required keyword idea here sugar free
ice cream is what i have searched for
now if you see at the bottom you will
see
the relevant keywords for sugar free ice
cream
with their average monthly searches
change
year on year change
competition
ads impression share bidding
with high and low etc so let me bring it
to you notice that from all the keywords
in the list not every keyword will be
important or will be useful for your
industry so while choosing a keyword
please be careful so always choose a
keyword with a good search volume higher
search volumes are always good
so by choosing keyword make sure that
monthly search volume is
at least between
1k to 10k or above so with monthly
search volumes you can see another
metric which is competition
it is a helpful metric during a keyword
research each keyword will either have a
high competition a low competition or a
medium competition
this metric helps the user to understand
the keyword difficulty or
how hard it is to rank for your website
for this particular keyword
a keyword with high competition have
more number of bidders
high competition keywords are mostly
taken up by the advertisers who are
willing to put up their ad campaigns
now talking about how to choose keywords
for organic rankings dear learners
competition metrics will also be helpful
here you will understand this in the
upcoming part of the video we have
already learned about long tail keywords
and short tail keywords
so now with the help of keyword type and
various metrics learned earlier
let's understand how to choose keywords
to get organic rankings
suppose
you have a new business
so initially it will be difficult to get
relevant audience for your site in such
a situation try getting a long tail
keyword with good search volume and low
competition
long tail keywords are helpful in
getting more accurate results if the
keyword is long tail
the chances of ranking it higher in the
search engine result pages
increases
however we are also choosing low
competition which suggests that
competition for keyword is low and the
chosen keyword can take a strong
position in the search results this can
help you to get more of the relevant
audience once you started getting more
and more traffic you can experiment with
short tail keywords with low medium and
high competition
now considering your business has a very
strong hold over a market
in such a situation you can simply
choose long tail keywords with good
search volume
and medium or high competition
this will help you to attract audiences
organically all through paid campaigns
next we will see search for trending
keywords
to get an instant spike in the traffic
trending keywords are the best ones to
be targeted
all you need to do is keep an eye on
what's the recent news or the trending
topic in your industry now create the
content targeting those keywords for
your website
for this you can make use of google
trends which will help you to identify
the trending keywords also you can
choose the search platforms like web
search youtube search etc or select the
geographical location as per your
requirement
well if you have great content then the
next strategy will be hundred percent
effective for your business which is
competitor keyword research
it is said that don't work hard work
smart
so let's try to do some smart work here
gather the list of competitors who are
doing well in your industry
now keep an eye on the keywords that
they are using to represent their
products and services
if those keywords benefit your
competitors
then
they will definitely prove fruitful for
your business as well to find competitor
keywords you can use various competitor
research tools
check the video on top 10 free seo tools
to get the best knowledge about
competitor research tools
you can get the link from the
description box below
the strategy of using competitor
keywords
works best for new as well as strong
businesses
next let me put a light on another
important keyword research strategy
which is
to identify search terms people are
looking for this is the best and
quickest way to attract audiences for
example i have an ice cream business
nowadays
people are more health conscious so
there is a possibility that
a person suffering from diabetes is
likely to search for sugar-free ice
creams near me or how to make a sugar
free ice cream
here i get one of the important keywords
with respect to my ice cream business
again if i say i have a tourism business
then i will look for the keywords around
travel and tourism now suppose a person
is looking for best location to spend
holidays
here i will get an important keyword to
highlight my tourism business in a
travel blog website
so now the question arises how to get
these keywords
dear learners to get such keyword ideas
just go to google.com and use auto
suggest features from google
all you need to do is simply type
whatever query you require
and you will get a list of
recommendation below recommendations are
the easiest way to understand what the
audience is actually looking for
now all you need to do is pin down all
these keywords and choose the relevant
one for your domain this strategy is
completely fair with new or any business
which has hold over a market
if you are interested in creating new
content
then try checking answer the public tool
which will give you the keyword ideas in
your industry that audience are actually
searching next we have is reverse
keyword mining
with this strategy we will try to dig
the keywords for which your website
appears in the search results
but may not get clicked let's see how it
is done
check the performance reports in the
google search console here you will get
list of keywords for which your site
appears
it is possible that your site may not
have accurate content and so may not get
clicks
and thereby gaining no traffic from that
keyword however these keyword ideas are
the indications that search engines
somewhere finds your content relevant to
these keywords and that is the reason
your website is getting several
impressions for that keyword
you can choose keywords and create
accurate content which will thereby
result in gaining a great audience for
your website
now that you are aware of how to do
keyword research let's try to understand
how to use keyword research tools and
implement the above strategies for
various scenarios
so we are going to demonstrate
few keyword research tools here
the number one is keyword planner
next is google trends and next we have
is sem rush
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more so now first we
will start with keyword planner
let's go to keyword planner
so here we are in the keyword planner
for those who are new to keyword planner
go to tools and settings and just click
on keyword planner
and there you come up with the keyword
planner tool
now let's consider that you have a
blogging site
and you're on a way to create a very
amazing and creative content
on how to make a sugar-free ice cream
so if you see here keyword planner works
in both ways
you can directly input your keyword and
get the list of keywords
or get the list of relevant keywords or
you can just add a
csv file and you can get the search
volume for already
researched keywords so now here i'll
just input
how to make
a
sugar
free
ice cream
and just hit enter you can
add your number of keywords to check so
for now i'm just adding one
and just click on get results
over here
you can see a large number of results
now you can see here none of the keyword
is having monthly search volume in
between 1k to 10k
so let's find another relevant keyword
so suppose we choose here sugar free ice
cream
and click on get results
so now here we got our main keyword as
sugar free ice cream which has 1k to 10k
of monthly searches
and yes definitely the competition is
high means there are a lot of
competitors and it is somewhat uh
difficult to rank with this keyword
but
we can take a trial for here
to choose this keyword as a main title
for our blog
again we have here sugar free ice cream
near me
so again this is somewhat location based
query so someone who is looking for the
ice cream centers near
them
so there is a possibility that those
audiences will be adding this query to
get the appropriate results
but this won't be
accurate for our blogging site to make a
sugar free ice cream
so
let's check what is there in the list
okay every keyword is high has a high
competition
so let's choose here sugar free ice
cream for our blog followed by some
other secondary keywords like sugar free
ice cream making or
how to make sugar free ice cream or low
sugar ice cream as their secondary
keywords
also there is a setting
to get the relevant keyword ideas as per
the location so here it is india so you
can choose a location
as per any country say this is china
you can choose for china as well
like here if you added china
there is a
okay so you will get the relevant result
as per china and india if you are not
selecting any of the country
then
we will be targeting all the countries
in the world
for that particular keyword
now let's take another example
to
find
now let's search for
best
jogging shoes
so let's see all the relevant ideas what
the planners suggest
so yes we got here best jogging shoes
maybe most of the audiences adding this
query to get the results so the
competition is quite high
in this case we can we can just select
the best jogging shoes and if you want
more specific then we can go with best
jogging shoes for men or women also i
would like to bring it to your notice
that please remember to choose the
relevant keywords as per your
requirement
there will be lots of results which
won't be
so relevant to your topic or to your
content
so make sure you're choosing the correct
keyword as per your content
after taking this keyword idea as best
jogging shoes you can just create a very
good content
either it may be a blog or an article
or a video
or a website content or text for the
website or anything you want to create
for best jogging shoes and make sure
that you are adding the this keyword
inside your
content
to make it more accurate for the search
engines
now next we move towards
our another keyword research tool which
is google trends
so
go to google.com and search for
google
trends
okay
so we are here
so
just to remind you google trend will uh
provide us with all the trending topics
or uh trending search terms
uh which can lead to a better ranking or
instant spike in your traffic
so suppose you are looking for the
latest trend in your industry
in that case
let's take again uh take an example of a
sugar free ice cream so i'll add here
sugar
free
ice cream okay i i just got the term in
the recommendations
it is from the food industry so just to
bring it to your notice from here we can
select the worldwide or any country
whatever we want to select
or check for this search query
then again we have a data for whatever
time duration we want the data for that
a particular search query
here we have a number of categories like
food industry entertainment etc etc
if you want to select you can just
choose it for now i'm not choosing here
anything and of course the web search
the email search
news search google and youtube search so
let's see uh let's select here youtube
search
and uh let's let's select here worldwide
so here we can get the insights
the interest over the time
so if you see here from
june 12
to 19 june there was a certain drop in
this keyword people were not searching
this keyword and again from 19 to 25
there is an increase in this keyword
like people are
more searching for this keyword
again you can see here the data
like interest by region so it is mostly
search
in australia
then followed by canada pakistan
united states united kingdom etc
and it also suggests you other related
queries here
now suppose
we want to compare it to
another search term say
ice cream maker let's see
the comparison between these two
search queries
okay
so if you can see here
from
july
2021
this keyword
ice cream maker is showing
a consistent small growth
whereas
the sugar free ice cream is
very much consistent there is not growth
or not much drop
both the graphs
are showing us these insights
so i hope you got a good knowledge about
google trends
how to use google trends
so let's see how to get some of the
competitor keywords
so for this we will go to sem rush
so here we are
to our sem rush tool so
sem rush is a all-in-one platform which
satisfies all the basic needs of search
engine optimization practices we get a
lot of like keyword research tool is
there competitor analysis tools is there
then we can identify the backlinks the
content gap the backlink gaps
and a lot of like an organic traffic for
your website and many more so please do
check out uh sem rush
you can find the link in the description
box below
and also it has a free as well as paid
version some of the searches are free
after which you can check on with the
paid plans also so we highly recommend
you to take a walkthrough through this
tool
now let's go to
the keyword gap
from here you can
get the ideas about you
and your competitor
so suppose
i'm adding here
okay so let's select the
country region here
and we are going for
we were using for the ice cream so let's
let's take
a mole
company
which is a mole.com
okay
dot com
and
another
can be
mother
theory
ice cream
it's www.motherdairy.com
so
www.motherdairy.com
okay
so let's do the check for india only
let's not
put it for usa
compare
okay so here you can see
a lot of
opportunities
keyword overlap
there are almost 1.7 k
like 1700 shared keywords
you can see the search volumes as well
and all the related data for both the
companies their products
and comparison
for
so here i am using a free plan for sem
rush
so i won't be able to show the complete
report here
but yes definitely we can export the all
the related data from
the competitor analysis
let's check for mobile
yes you can see here the
large difference between the overlap
keywords
you can also get the data for the
organic keywords paid keywords
paid keywords are mainly those keywords
which are used for advertising purposes
you can change the date here
and all the data to get whatever kind of
results or data or insights you want
i hope now you have mastered the keyword
research techniques let us now see how
keyword research is important
as a job role
now coming to the job opportunities
keyword research is the most important
part of any role in search engine
optimization or digital marketing the
job descriptions in seo and digital
marketing are likely to include keyword
research under the job requirements like
performing keyword research including
discovery and expansion of keyword
opportunities
or
perform keyword research in coordination
with client business objectives to
optimize existing content and discover
new opportunities
or to conduct keyword research using
various tools
is the basic template for the job
description for seo analyst
here you can see the first job
responsibility is to perform keyword
research using various keyword research
tools like keyword planner
so this itself suggests that how keyword
research is very much important in
search engine optimization or
digital marketing jobs
here are some of the companies which are
hiring for seo profiles
so the companies includes microsoft
disney siemens udemy deloitte etc
however every online business requires
seo strategies to grow and so the
companies hiring for seo profiles are
not restricted to these five companies
so moving ahead
let's see what the future of keyword
research holds
performing keyword research in a smart
way can bring you all the golden traffic
for your website
gaining a relevant audience is always
fruitful for any business
however it is recommended not to stay
limited to keyword research
you also need to keep an eye on how
keywords are actually performing are
they really driving the relevant traffic
if not then recheck the content and
align keywords identify the gaps and
update the content accordingly google
analytics 4
google analytics is a web analytics
service offered by google
it was launched back in 2005.
it tracks and reports website traffic
from the information through wikipedia
google analytics is the most used web
analytics service as per the sources in
april 2022
google analytics was used by 73
of the 10 000 most popular website
across the globe
however as per the reports from
beltway.com
two crore 81 lakh 52
477 live websites use google analytics
so now this is the time to understand
what has been changed in google
analytics over the years
if you are new to google analytics it's
even better
before moving forward
do subscribe to simply learn and hit the
bell icon to never miss any updates from
simply learn so what makes google
analytics so important
google analytics generates various types
of reports and helps to track bounce
rates
identify the best content
of your website record user behavior
flow on your site and many other metrics
thereby allowing you to understand and
build your business strategies
thereby growing your business
now that you have understood why google
analytics is essential
let's check what we have for you in this
video
first we will understand what is google
analytics for
then we will move forward with
identifying google analytics version for
your website
next we will have a detailed look at
universal analytics and google analytics
4.
we will continue by understanding
success stories from google analytics
for users
and finally we will end this session by
understanding the future of google
analytics sport
so allow me to introduce the next
generation of google analytics
google analytics 4
also known as ga4 initially google
analytics 4 was known as app plus web
google analytics 4 is the latest
analytics property with several
advantages over the old google analytics
also known as universal analytics
understanding more clearly google
analytics sport can measure and keep
track of website traffic as well as app
usage
so now you can imagine that google
analytics 4 is the one-stop solution for
all your analytics needs
if you are still using universal
analytics we recommend you to get
familiar with google analytics 4 as well
as this is the new future of analytics
we will understand creating and setting
up google analytics for account in
detail in the upcoming videos
let's first identify which google
analytics property is associated with
your website
in order to identify which google
analytics property you have
login to your google analytics account
now go to analytics account
and then open properties and apps
here you can see properties for your
website
now
below the properties and apps several
properties are listed
where
you can see different ids
if the id starts with ua
and ends with a number
then you have a universal analytics
property
however if id only has numbers
like here
then you have google analytics for
property
we will learn how to switch the
universal analytics account to google
analytics 4 in the upcoming videos
now that you have understood how to
identify google analytics property
let's take a detailed look at the
comparison of universal analytics data
and google analytics 4 data
the major difference between universal
analytics and google analytics 4 is the
measurement model
universal analytics uses sessions and
page views as the measurement model
whereas google analytics 4 uses events
and parameters as the measurement model
therefore any hit type from universal
analytics property say a page view user
timing etc are captured as event in
google analytics for property
let's see the detailed comparison
of every aspect of universal analytics
and google analytics 4.
first we go with events
in analytics every measurable action for
example page load form completion
scrolls app installs etc is measured as
event
an event has category
label
and action in universal analytics
moreover it has its own hit type
in case of google analytics 4 there is
no categorization all the hit types from
universal analytics are considered as
events
now let's find the comparison of
universal analytics and google analytics
4 in terms of page views
page views is a metric defined that
calculates total number of pages viewed
on your website now let's get a better
understanding of page views
for instance when user lands on the web
page of your site
the page loads
this is considered to be a page view
now suppose if user reloads the page
google analytics tracks it as another
page view
if the user navigates to another page of
your website and returns to the same
page
this adds another page view to your site
now that you have understood page views
let's see how page views differs
in universal analytics and google
analytics sport
from universal analytics
page view are translated to google
analytics for property
as page view event
this pageview event
automatically gets triggered in google
tag manager
the next metric we have
is sessions
session is a time duration for which
user is active on your website
a universal analytics session may
consist of multiple page views
events
e-commerce transactions etc
the session is considered to be ended if
the user has 30 minutes of inactivity or
any other event for which session end is
triggered
in google analytics 4 session metrics
are tracked from session start event
which automatically gets triggered with
the basic interaction on your website
however the session duration depends on
the period between the first and the
last event
now let's check our next metric which is
custom dimension
in universal analytics custom dimension
add the information to the collected
data
whereas in google analytics 4
information is added through the event
parameters
moving ahead
the next metric we have is content
grouping
content grouping in universal analytics
allows to group content into a logical
structure
after which one can view and compare
metrics by the group name
now talking about google analytics 4 it
has predefined event parameter for
content group this parameter fills the
data into content group moving ahead
the next metric we have is client id
client id is a unique string generated
randomly and acts as a pseudonomous
identifier
client id identifies the browser
instance and then it gets stored in the
browser cookies
and therefore subsequent visits to the
same site are associated with that user
in both
universal analytics and google analytics
4 client id serves the same purpose
that is the client id is responsible for
providing the identifier
now let's move ahead with our next
metric
parameters
parameters are associated with google
analytics four properties
understanding in detail about parameters
parameters are the chunk of information
that specifies the user action
for example parameters can be passed
to describe the value of the purchase
next we have is user property
user properties provide information like
preferred language or geographical
location of the users that interact with
your website or app
now that we have seen difference between
universal analytics and google analytics
four properties
the question definitely arises
can google analytics really bring
success to your business
well if you have a good understanding of
your audience and have extraordinary
strategies to work on
the google analytics is your best
companion
here are some success stories by google
analytics for users
we all know about mcdonald's the leading
fast food corporation with huge number
of outlets across the globe
recently a case study has been shared by
mcdonald's hong kong which suggests that
the company has experienced growth in
conversions by 550 percent through the
in-app orders
and what made them achieve such a great
growth
yes you guessed it right it's google
analytics 4.
let's have a look on their success story
the major goal for the company was to
redesign the strategy to increase in-app
food orders
predict the behavior of in-app audiences
and reach the right customers with
mcdonald's mobile order campaigns to
achieve the goals mcdonald use a simple
yet smart approach and implemented
google analytics for properties
with the help of predictive audiences in
google analytics four properties they
tried converting audiences into
customers
moreover with the help of google ads
they were able to manage the campaigns
as a result of the smart efforts
mcdonald was able to gain increase in
conversions by 550 percent for the users
who are likely to purchase in next seven
days
isn't it amazing
moreover for the same audience
mcdonald's had noticed a visible
decrease in cost per action by 63
percent
and an increase in revenue by 560
percent
some other companies that have seen
growth in their business through google
analytics sport includes pepsico
claroshop etc
with the proven success of top brands in
the world let us know what the future of
google analytics 4 holds as per the
reports on buildwith.com
there are two crore 81 lakh 52
477 live websites that are using google
analytics
out of which there are one crore 21 lakh
73
413 live websites from usa
and 4 lakh 68
538 live websites from india
who are using google analytics if you
look in detail we have a list of big
names like bank of america
blogger.com
cisco
netflix
coursera
flipkart
icici bank
tesla india
irctc
myntra etc that are using google
analytics for their growth
however we are all well aware of the
success stories of all the biggies on
the list
thus google analytics will continue to
be an important part of new business
strategies
things you should know before we end
this session are
google analytics 4 will be soon
replacing universal analytics
from 1st july 2023
the universal analytics platform will be
no longer an action
however you will be able to access the
reports for some period of time
google analytics 4 will be the new
future of analytics
have you ever wondered what will happen
if the pages of your website are not
visible in the search engines
definitely this can be the most scary
thought you ever had
but
due to lack of technical knowledge this
is happening in the real world with the
newbies in the seo industry
well for these beginners
this video is the opportunity and the
solution to your problems
to get your pages search and appear in
google search results
it is important that these pages
are indexed in google
and to get the web pages index
google search console
or search console
is the one-stop solution
before we dive deep into this topic
consider subscribing to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss any
updates from simply line
in this video we are going to cover all
the basics of search console like what
is search console and its importance
the working of search console
the google search console complete guide
for 2022
that covers all the basics of google
search console
we will discuss about the companies
hiring the candidates with required
skill sets
in search console in seo industry
section and we will end this session by
knowing how search console will continue
to be in action for many more years
so dear learners
if you want to get upskilled for free
then do give it a try for simply learns
advanced search engine optimization
program
which comes with the completion
certificate
and in-depth knowledge about seo and seo
techniques
check this course details from the link
in the description box below
so let's start by knowing what is search
console
google search console formerly known as
google webmaster tool is a web service
provided by google developers
google search console is mainly
responsible
for optimizing a website for its
visibility
indexing website
detecting crawl errors etc
after understanding what is google
search console
now we need to focus on why search
console is an important part of search
engine optimization
a website's technicalities are directly
or indirectly related to search console
consider
you have created a website for your
business
but from past few weeks your website is
not visible in search result pages here
search console comes into action
there is a possibility that search
engine crawlers are not able to crawl
your website
thus it is not visible in the search
result pages
to make crawlers crawl your website
you will need to optimize your website
using search console
some other technical aspects of search
console includes
fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or pages for
indexing
generating search traffic reports
generating alerts
if there are any issues
related to indexing or any other issue
gets the list of sites linking to your
website
keep the track of mobile usability
amp pages
and more
so now it is the right time to
understand how search console works
but before we begin this topic
have a look at the range of courses
of digital marketing and search engine
optimization from skillup by simplyland
you can get the link in the description
box below
so now i have a question for you
what will you do at first
if your web page fails to appear in
search result pages
well let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below
stay tuned with this video
even though if you don't have the answer
right now by the end of this video you
will surely able to answer this question
so let's get started by knowing how
search console works
to understand the working of search
console it is necessary to have a
detailed knowledge about how search
engine works
search engines mainly works in three
steps crawling indexing and ranking
let's have a look at each step one by
one
so first let's start with crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send web spiders or web
crawlers also known as robots or search
engine bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image a web page a
video or anything else present on the
web this process is known as crawling
now let's know about indexing
as soon as the crawler discover the
updated content or new content
these web crawlers start storing the
urls of the content into the search
index or web index
this process is known as indexing once
the content is indexed it starts
appearing in the search result pages
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant results
are taken from the index
and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result pages this process is known as
ranking
now that we have gained knowledge about
how search engine works here i have a
question for you
choose the correct option with respect
to working of search engines you need to
choose the option
for all the steps of how search engines
work
option a indexing crawling ranking
option b
ranking indexing crawling
c
crawling indexing ranking and option d
crawling ranking and indexing
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
now let's get started by learning how
search console actually works
search console is a primary source of
information
that helps search engine bots to crawl
index and rank the pages of your website
thereby allowing the website owners to
monitor the health of your website
all you need to do is integrate search
console with your website and get the
ownership
allow the search engine words to crawl
your website
and index the pages
also don't forget to submit your website
site map to search engines submitting
site maps helps the crawler to discover
more pages of your website
thereby understanding your site's
architecture
we will know how it is done in the
upcoming part of the video
also you need to keep an eye on the
errors suggested by search console and
solve them else it may harm the ranking
of your website
now let me remind you that all the
reports that are generated in search
console are based on the activity of the
web crawlers on your website
now let's understand various parameters
and terminologies from search console
to get a complete understanding of this
webmaster tool
so without any further delay let's start
understanding the basic terminologies of
google search console and how they work
and improve your website's health
the first one we have is performance
reports
google search console provides two types
of performance report search reports and
discover reports
let's first understand about search
reports
search reports help to analyze the
search performance of your website
search performance reports include
metrics and dimensions
so let's first focus on metrics
here there are four types of metrics as
you can see in this image
the metrics include the total clicks or
i must say clicks impressions
average ctr and average position
impressions provides the data on how
many times your websites appears in the
search results
as you can see here
the graph shows the number of times this
website has appeared in the search
results
the next metric we have is clicks
clicks provide the data on the total
number of times users clicked from the
search results and reached your website
the graph below
shows the number of times the users have
clicked from search results and they
have arrived on the any page of my
website so suppose if here is a number
200 so we can definitely get an idea
for very number of dates number of dates
provided on the x-axis which shows that
how many times
the user has clicked and arrived on the
website and the number varies and varies
from between like 200 200
uh 250 300 and in between 250 to 300
and the next metric we have is average
ctr
average ctr or click-through rate is the
percentage of impressions that results
in clicks
in the same manner the graph below shows
the average ctr for various different
dates
the next metric we have is
average position the average position
represents the data about the average
position of the sites in the search
results
it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at three some other
day at four some other day at nine or
ten and again it may rank to the one so
this data actually provides the detail
about the average position
uh which your website frequently ranks
at
so that is if it is ranking at one two
and three in between one two and three
positions so the average position may be
2.
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from where
here is the list of dimensions on which
the dimension performance reports are
generated that is
the countries pages queries
devices search appearance and dates
the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came
as you can see here from the
left column you can get the list of
number of countries from the right side
you can get the idea about the clicks
impressions ctr and position that is all
the metrics related to that query uh uh
from which the search came from or from
that location
or whatever the activity has happened
from that location
next we have is the dimensions pages
pages show the pages clicked by user or
a page that is viewed on a search
so
this this actually you get the reports
from the search console in the form of
the links where you get the link which
is the exact page
that is viewed on the search
if there exists duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links
like if there are suppose
there is a one original page and there
are two three duplicate page of the same
page so what happens uh
the original page gains the canonical
link and uh
this page has more value than the
duplicate pages
so whenever the search engine will crawl
your website all the duplicate pages may
be ignored and all its
link juice or link equity or anything
will be
completely taken for the original page
uh moving ahead to queries
queries provide the query string that
users search on the google search
console
so suppose there is a website say
suppose uh
let's talk about the simply learn
website so suppose a user may
add as java course and simply learn
websites appears at second or third
position
so this query
say suppose user clicks on the website
and reaches the website this query java
course on simply learn or java course
will add in the search console
showing that the user has reached to
your website using
this query java course
and again all the list of the queries
appears towards the left and all the
matrixes for that query like clicks
impressions ctr and its average uh
position is appeared towards the right
in the search console
now talking about the search appearance
search appearance helps in grouping the
data as per the search result type or by
the feature
so you can get here the number of search
appearance and again the same matrixes
with respect to the search appearance
criteria next let's move towards the
dates
dates groups the data as per the dates
according to the public time zones now
let's have a look over the discover
performance report now here you must be
thinking
about how the search is different from
discover
yes search and discover follow different
approaches
users enter a query to find a required
information with search
whereas
discover shows the content based on what
result will be best match for your query
as per the google's automated system
now coming to the discover performance
report as per google's guidelines
discover performance reports are visible
only if your website has a minimum
threshold of impressions in discover
now moving to another important
parameter of search console which is url
inspection
url inspection is an interesting tool in
the search console
this tool allows you to inspect whether
the url is indexable or not
some main functions of this tool
includes
checking the current status of the url
inspecting live urls requesting indexing
for a url
viewing pages rendered version
viewing crawled pages
viewing tested pages etc
in order to check the index status of
url
open the url inspection tool
and add the complete url
for which we need to know its indexing
status
now to understand the results check the
present status
if it shows that url is on google as you
can see in the screen
this means that
url qualifies google's criteria and is
eligible to appear in search results
if it shows url is not on google
then the url does not qualify the
google's criteria and is not eligible to
appear in search results
you can check more details like url
discovery crawl and indexing information
from the page availability tab
click on the crawl page to see the
information about the http request and
response
if you find that the link is disabled
just hover over the page to check the
reason
now coming to the live url test
it is helpful to test the live url and
check if it is capable of being indexed
it proves helpful
when you update your page and want to
compare it with its latest indexed
version just to bring it to your notice
a live test will only confirm whether
the google crawler can access your page
for indexing
but it doesn't assure that your page
will be included in the google index
altogether with the help of index
coverage report one can find the list of
urls which includes the urls google has
found on your website the urls that have
been indexed and identify if any
indexing problem have occurred
next we move ahead to understand about
the site maps
a site map is the file that contains all
the information of pages on your website
this helps search engine crawlers
to crawl your website and understand
your website structure
and helps them to index the pages more
efficiently
more the crawler indexes your pages
higher the chances for the pages of your
website to appear in the search results
with the help of site maps you can
provide information about various
contents like pages videos images etc
as you can understand a site map plays
an important role in indexing process
you must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a sitemap to search
engines
before we understand this process make
sure that all pages of your website are
linked in an appropriate manner with
each other thereby maintaining a healthy
site structure
a site map can be created in xml format
rss format or in text format
it can be auto generated or created
manually as well
most commonly used
site map is xml
following is an example of an xml site
map
this is the simplest version of the site
map that we are representing here you
can submit a site map to the sitemap
reports in the search console
however sitemaps can also be submitted
through
robots.txt file
let's understand about
robots.txt file
so let's understand the
robots.txt file in short
robots.txt file notifies the web
crawlers
about the urls that they can access on
the website as there are lots of search
engines
there exist different web crawlers thus
there is a possibility that some web
crawlers may not obey the instructions
from the robots.txt file
it is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax differently
thus there are chances that some web
crawlers might fail to understand the
instructions from the robots.txt file
a page can be indexed even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked
to other site
next let's know what enhancement reports
are
all the rich results status reports are
displayed under the enhancement tab
so let's know more about rich results
these type of results are known as rich
results in serps so basically rich
results can be any search results other
than the traditional blue links for
example image results carousels etc
you can check whether the pages from
your website support rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by google developers
now understanding the rich results
status report the enhancement tab
contains separate reports for rich
result type
some rich result report types are listed
below that are breadcrumbs
education q a event faq
fact check
guided recipe
how to
image license
job posting
learning video
review snippets etc
rich results status reports consist of
summary page and details page
the summary page mainly consists of
errors useful items found on your
website
warnings etc the details page consists
of the information about the issues
when it was detected item type
when was the page last crawled etc
before we understand how to fix error in
search console it is important to
understand the status of each page as
reported by search console
each page has any of the following
status error
warning excluded and valid
if the status of the page is valid it
means
the page has successfully indexed
the status of the page appears to be
excluded
if one purposefully wants the page not
to be indexed
or a page is blocked by robots.txt file
for example setting the meta tag to no
index
warnings majorly appears
when the page of your website is indexed
but there are some issues with the page
which needs your attention
and have to be resolved as soon as
possible
if the page's status is error
then
there is a need to pay a detailed
attention over the issues in the page as
these issues prevent the page from
getting indexed
let's discuss about the errors in detail
and how we can fix them
some popular errors from the search
console are listed below
that is the redirect error
server error submitted urls blocked by
robots.txt
url marked as no index
submitted url is a soft 404
404 or page not found error
so let's first know about the redirect
error
some redirect error
that search control shows up are the
redirect chain that was too long
redirect rule
redirect url that exists maximum url
length
and bad or empty url in the redirect
chain
so all these error means that the
redirections are not working properly
and so there is a need to fix them so
suppose for example you have added too
many redirects
from one page to another
so in this scenario
search engine bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again to the
same redirections and at that time the
search engine crawlers or search engine
boats ignore those urls or redirections
so in such cases you need to fix those
redirection to a single url
the next we have is server error
the server returns 5x error when it
fails to fulfill a valid request this
error mainly conveys that something is
wrong with your website server all you
need to do is reach out to your hosting
services
and inform them about the issue and make
sure it gets resolved as soon as
possible
the next one we have is submitted url
blocked by
robots.txt to resolve this issue you
need to remove the line of code from the
robot.txt file that
restricts google from crawling the
respective page
the next we have is url marked as no
index
when a url is marked as no index it
sends the signal to crawlers that this
page is not meant to be crawled or this
page is not meant to be indexed if you
want this page to be indexed check the
metadata and remove the no index
attribute to allow the crawlers to crawl
the url
now let's understand about the error
submitted url is a soft 404
and four note 4 or page not found error
whenever a web page load server returns
a 200 signal showing the success status
code sort 4 note 4 is a condition
in which server returns 2 0 0 success
status code and the page not exist
errors simultaneously
this is considered to be a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
url
or the home page of the website
talking about 404 or page not found
error
this error mainly occurs
when you delete the page from your
website but the url of the page still
exists in the site map
this error can be solved by simply
removing the url
or removing the 4.4 url from the site
map or redirecting the url to a new page
this will help to avoid the further
errors in near future
we will have a detailed look at other
four xx errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console
let's dive deeper to know some stats
regarding the search console in the seo
industry
when you're thinking of adding a
business online your website should
fulfill all the technical seo needs
which can be achieved by google search
console
thus there is a huge demand in seo
industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of google search
console
the average salary of an seo expert
with the google search console skills in
u.s
is
53 000
to 78 000
per annum and that in india
is 2 lakh 76 000 per annum some biggies
in the seo industry
looking for this skill sets include
accenture amazon people group eton etc
so let me know your dream company to
work as an seo expert in the comment
section below
well if you're looking for the same
opportunity to be a skilled professional
in search engine optimization
then you are at the right place
simply learns search engine optimization
training course
will groom you to become industry ready
seo specialist
check the description box below to know
the complete details of the course and
click on the link to grab the
opportunity search console is for
everyone whether you are a business
owner a marketing specialist a web
developer or a website administrator
google search console will continue to
be the part of search engine
optimization technique
and will keep on playing a major role in
the maintenance of the website and
improvement in rankings before ending
this video if you like this session
consider subscribing to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss any
updates from simply learn stay tuned
with simply learn and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here